by the way I didn't even play the
package from Eric in Los Angeles
high-pitch Eric if you follow the show
he now has a driver's license which is
terrifying I am terrified of that
information we didn't invite Eric to be
part of our Los Angeles shows but he
decided to show up anyway and he got
quite belligerent with us when we said
we don't need you there but he said I'm
coming to LA his plan was to fly to Los
Angeles and then rent a car and he had
only gotten his driver's license a few
days before he left so he was like a new
driver in a new town he like you know
he's confusing places where's Shirley
Shirley went driving with high pitch
high pitch and Shirley made plans for
lunch the first day in Los Angeles Eric
drove to where our staff was staying in
the hotel right Eric showed up at the
hotel yeah like Tony Soprano in a big
SUV smoking a cigar I mean it's hard
enough for him to drive but he's smoking
a cigar he's holding the cigar what is
he driving with one hand yeah like he's
been doing it for 20 years
Wow how many tickets has he gotten now
okay so if you remember when we were in
LA he was bragging that he had nine
pieces of mail come to his house that
were all camera light tickets from
traffic lights since then Howard I just
got a tally from him in the green room
he's had a total he's had seven more
since we've been back Wow
so that's a total of 16 tickets [ __ ]
speeding yeah yeah $50 a pop that's $800
where's the tickets where is this guy
get in here see what he's worried what
does he worry he's lured a singlet like
Andre the Giant Oh for the weigh-in yet
yeah you see wow it looks good
Wow poor we weigh in on my bulk and
thank you for doing that but I'm talking
about Los Angeles and you're driving
listen I am terrified you're driving I
when I first got my driver's license I
got into a bad action - on the same - -
right one in the day one at night the
nighttime my car is totally I couldn't
drive me home right right right
and the body shop why are you laughing
great brand no yeah
and how much did you pay nine thousand
yeah how much was the whole car
twenty-two right amazing price of the
car keeps going up all right look I am
terrified of you driving because when we
did the rehearsal for you to get into
the scale yeah to teach you how to do it
Kari said you couldn't even understand
that you have to sit in the scale until
the bits over [ __ ] like you blanked out
I don't know how you passed your
driver's test it's it's unthinkable to
me when you ask him a question yeah when
he gets overloaded so we know that high
pitch doesn't work but you know now he's
got now he's got a convertible but that
didn't work out because his belly was
too big what happened you you went to
the rental place right and your belly
would hit the steering wheel right and
so because of the tension of the belly
hold it like you couldn't turn the wheel
buddy buddy told me every time he
breathed the horn excuse me mister high
pitch your belly would hit their
steering wheel and hit the horn
those who snug yeah all right so ma'am
yeah well at least you were polite okay
so high-pitched and Shirley made plans
for lunch their first day in Los Angeles
Eric drove to the staffs hotel to pick
Shirley up within a minute of driving
high-pitch nearly got into an accident
his road rage was on full display I will
play the clip this is turning turning
around making a u-turn to go out of the
hotel and you're sitting in the car with
I'm in the front seat brain all right
very tense in LA are you finding the
traffic's making you tense the drivers
yeah people don't know how to drive it's
not like New York whoa well I don't know
people not to concentrate on [ __ ] Oh
[ __ ] grunts oh you're laughing at that
you think you don't you're not alarmed
by that no that's how you drive you
everyone's wrong but you in other words
everyone on the road doesn't know how to
drive but you know how people drive a to
five miles an hour on the way to lunch
high-pitched old Shirley that he almost
killed a homeless person while driving
in Los Angeles at night here is the
conversation so I heard you almost hit a
homeless person
well he's homeless that's where he lives
fine it wasn't my fault but you have to
keep aware you have to pay attention
back outside that kind Sam well then you
shouldn't be driving a night I just
couldn't see him really really is it
really is like talking to a [ __ ] wall
you understand you have to be able to
see at night in order to drive what I
mean you can't see what I just ran
we're responsible he ran into the street
responsible I by the way surely Congrats
on being our bravest reporter ever were
you really scared you Hanabi I remember
there was just a dead line of cars all
there brake lights on and he's hauling
ass he doesn't know how to drive I feel
comfortable
Ronnie's crazy if he doesn't know how to
drive right well in Hollywood there are
people who dress up like superheroes for
tourists during the drive high-pitch saw
a Wonder Woman and Catwoman got
completely distract my god this is from
the car and he's trying to make a right
turn so he's almost on the sidewalk
disaster and I just want to get back to
the hotel I'm texted my wife and told
her I love her high pitches road rage
was out of control for the entire Drive
this is a montage of Eric and the car
with Shirley this is the scariest part
it even fit in all the moments but here
we go watch it [ __ ]
let's go what are you doing
[ __ ] [ __ ] you can't move the Twinner
all right I mean the day of confronting
me [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
what's it mean when you say they have
Florida plates in other words their
out-of-towners yes but you're an out of
town or two you were in LA but I but I
had my ways I had my you know join me
maybe a fall
maybe that guy with the floor the plates
no way he was going nicely I may never
drive again
Howard that was the most frightening
part cuz la they'll get out and beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of you for home a Jew a
bit late probably people like wait a
second I think Mickey Mouse just called
me a [ __ ]